[Música]
aquí inicia un nuevo capítulo de áfrica
siete días en france 24 este es un
magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
la cita detenidos tras más de una semana
de protestas en sudáfrica superó los
3.400 las víctimas fatales son más de
200 los comerciantes son los más
afectados o tras los saqueos y las
autoridades iniciaron las labores de
limpieza en las diferentes ciudades del
país la unión europea y el consejo de
derechos humanos de naciones unidas
existen la necesidad de tomar medidas
frente a la hambruna que golpea a los
habitantes de la disputada región etíope
del tigre además piden que se retiren
las tropas eritreas solicitud rechazada
tanto por el gobierno de eritrea como
por el de etiopía
y casi un mes después de su regreso a
costa de marfil el ex candidato
presidencial loren back bo anunció una
alianza con su antiguo rival el también
opositor henri konan bédié ambos planea
fortalecer una nueva fuerza política que
podría cambiar los destinos del país
utilizamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
sudáfrica porque la cifra de detenidos
superó las 3.400 personas después de más
de una semana de manifestaciones saqueos
y disturbios en el marco del estallido
social desatado tras el ingreso a
prisión del ex presidente jacob zuma
además las protestas dejan un saldo de
200 12 víctimas fatales
el país conmemoró el día de nelson
mandela en medio de labores de limpieza
en algunas de las ciudades más afectadas
el presidente sudafricano cyril
ramaphosa se unió a una jornada en
johannesburgo
barriendo escombros y basura durante las
protestas 161 centros comerciales 11
bodegas 8 fábricas y además varios
puntos de venta licores resultaron
afectados por los saqueos mandatario
insiste en que las violentas protestas
fueron instigadas
fuimos infiltrados hubo personas que
vinieron un enemigo invisible con el que
estamos luchando
que continuaremos combatiendo y
derrotando
y puedo decir que vamos a derrotarlos
porque no tiene la misma fuerza que
tenemos en relación con gente joven como
ustedes nuestro gobierno nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad las personas de
soweto y el pueblo de sudáfrica
y es que la nación austral vivió más de
una semana de intensas manifestaciones
en diferentes ciudades quedaron también
en saqueos y disturbios ahora se vive
una tensa calma pero decenas de locales
quedaron afectados y hay escasez de
combustible y alimentos
después de más de una semana de
manifestaciones y saqueos en sudáfrica
el panorama sigue siendo tenso en las
principales ciudades los más afectados
son los comerciantes
fuerte es desgarrador ver lo que has
construido y lo que ha desaparecido es
un dolor de corazón es lo que le pasa a
todos los demás gerentes de negocios es
lo que está pasando allá afuera no es
agradable no es agradable de ver para
todos y mientras tanto la preocupación
por la escasez de alimentos y de
combustibles se extiende a todo el país
y las giras son cada vez más largas por
su parte el gobierno intenta
tranquilizar a la población pedimos a
los ciudadanos que mantengan la calma en
estos tiempos difíciles el gobierno está
trabajando con el consejo nacional de
bienes de consumo para garantizar la
seguridad alimentaria las principales
ciudades del país se ven envueltas en
una espiral de violencia alimentada por
la crisis económica y una tasa de
desempleo de más del 30 por ciento los
primeros incidentes estallaron un día
después de que el ex presidente jacob
zuma fuera encarcelado por 15 meses por
desacato la chispa que era de vivo las
frustraciones económicas
hablamos ahora de etiopía porque el
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
alertó nuevamente sobre la crisis de
hambruna que se vive en la región del
tigre además una resolución de la unión
europea insiste en la necesidad de
combatir justamente la falta de
alimentos y retirar las tropas eritreas
de esta región que han estado ayudando
al gobierno central de etiopía el
conflicto de más de ocho meses deja más
de dos millones de desplazados y 400.000
personas en situación de hambruna duras
palabras en ginebra- contra las
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
tigre
el consejo de la onu de derechos humanos
expresó preocupación por los abusos
cometidos por etiopía y eritrea y pidió
la retirada de las tropas eritreas
señalando las de agravar el conflicto
sin la resolución propuesta por la unión
europea tuvo 20 votos a favor 14 en
contra y 13 abstenciones
la situación sobre el terreno no ha
mejorado y seguimos muy preocupados la
gente está sufriendo en tigre
intégrate
eritrea en un inicio negó la presencia
de sus tropas en apoyo al gobierno
central de etiopía ahora rechazan haber
cometido abusos dan balance da provecho
al psoe la desequilibrada resolución
ignora el inicio de la crisis y traslada
la culpa a ciertos actores olvidando el
principal responsable de la cuestión
christina gdem eilc al crit en depresión
la escalada internacional del conflicto
también ha desvelado aliados del
gobierno de etiopía china y venezuela
presentaron junto a eritrea más de una
docena de enmiendas
la resolución no refleja los esfuerzos
del gobierno de etiopía para mejorar la
asistencia humanitaria y complicará la
situación del tigre los enfrentamientos
empezaron en tigre hace 8 meses entre el
frente de liberación popular de tigre
gobernante en la región y el gobierno
del primer ministro y premio nobel de la
paz había metal y que lanzó una cruenta
ofensiva para sacarlo del poder el
conflicto ha dejado centenares de
fallecidos dos millones de desplazados y
cuatrocientas mil personas al borde de
la hambruna
durante meses la región estuvo cerrada a
la llegada de ayuda humanitaria que por
fin ha comenzado a fluir a través del
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
pues justamente un equipo periodístico
de france24 visitó la región del tigre
en etiopía y habló con algunos de sus
habitantes aquí les mostramos la
situación que enfrentan en medio de la
hambruna y también del conflicto hace
dos meses este hombre lo perdió todo en
el corazón de estas montañas de tigre
soldados eritreos masacraron a varias
personas de su pueblo escondidas en un
hueco de un acantilado estas tumbas son
el único rastro visible que queda de la
matanza desde el principio del conflicto
soldados eritreos apoyan al ejército
etíope contra las fuerzas disidentes del
tigre numerosos testigos acusan a los
eritreos de haber perpetrado masacres y
violaciones por toda la región como aquí
la mayoría de las zonas rurales son
difícilmente accesibles a las ong debido
al conflicto este equipo médico debe con
frecuencia replegarse a la capital
incluso cuando no hay combates los
desplazamientos son limitados hoy
habíamos previsto ir a algunos pueblos y
los vecinos nos esperaban pero en el
camino fuimos controlados por soldados
etíopes que nos impidieron pasar
les explicamos que atendemos a las
mujeres y a los niños estamos muy
preocupados por ellos
el equipo se detiene finalmente en este
pequeño pueblo en pleno centro de tigre
en estas regiones rurales recibir un
tratamiento médico se volvió un lujo
incluso obtener alimento es difícil la
desnutrición afecta especialmente a los
niños
está perdiendo peso tiene una orden para
que puedas recibir alimentos especiales
el cese al fuego unilateral declarado
por el gobierno el 28 de junio deja
entrever una situación humanitaria muy
preocupante según la onu 350.000
personas están en situación de hambruna
han tigre
cambiamos de información porque casi un
mes después de regresar a costa de
márfil el ex presidente laurent gbagbo
se reunió con su antiguo rival y nuevo
aliado henri konan bédié su encuentro
fue una oportunidad para fortalecer la
alianza de las dos más importantes
figuras de la oposición marfileña
un encuentro muy simbólico y una cálida
bienvenida está escena tuvo lugar en la
ucr o la ciudad natal de bédié los
antiguos rivales políticos convertidos
en aliados hombre y konan bédié y logan
backbone se reunieron por última vez
hace dos años en la capital belga esta
vez decidieron reunirse rodeados de sus
seguidores políticos el mensaje es claro
las dos figuras de la oposición ahora
están trabajando juntos
[Música]
daré todo a todas las fuerzas que me
quedan al servicio de la verdadera
reconciliación por nuestro país
tumba confianza
estoy toda mi confianza y creo que
lograremos nuestro sueño
back boat también le habló a la multitud
el ex presidente que regresó a costa de
márfil hace casi un mes después de una
ausencia de 10 años fue recibido
calurosamente por los asistentes al
encuentro la nueva alianza política no
dejó pasar el tema las últimas
elecciones presidenciales una votación
que fue boicoteada por la oposición ya
que el actual presidente a las anotara
tomó la controvertida decisión de
postularse para un tercer mandato
y si luchas contra la constitución
podemos decir que no estamos de acuerdo
y ha recorrido un largo camino tenemos
que seguir la corriente
y está recibiendo abajo en el tiempo es
tan importante es más grande que mi vida
a dos años de las elecciones locales en
el país la alianza entre los dos
políticos podría cambiar las reglas del
juego para la oposición marfileña
hablamos de ciencia porque por primera
vez un asteroide el sistema solar lleva
el nombre de un senegalés se trata de
maracay de un astrónomo de 42 años que
ha sido homenajeado por la unión
astronómica internacional es el
presidente del asociación senegalesa
para la promoción de la astronomía
el científico recientemente dirigió dos
misiones para la nasa desde su país en
france 24 hablamos con él
[Música]
lo que tiene de particular es que es
parte de este cinturón de asteroides que
como usted lo dijo se encuentra entre
marte y júpiter y donde quedan residuos
la creación del sistema solar que al
estudiarlos nos permite y devolvernos
entre 4.000 y 5.000 años en el pasado
este asteroide órbita alrededor del sol
y tomó aproximadamente 1500 días para
dar una vuelta es decir que toma más o
menos cuatro años
es un elemento bastante simple y
pensamos que está compuesto de golitos
con una superficie bastante simple que
no es sencilla de detectar que sobrevive
y que fue descubierta en 1998 en el
marco de un proyecto donde un equipo de
astrónomos hicieron descubrimientos
durante toda su trayectoria
atrás virtual cada 18 de julio se
conmemora el día internacional de nelson
mandela y aquí en áfrica siete días los
celebramos con un clásico de la música
sudafricana en la voz del granjero como
hace que la y su canción bring back home
en su versión en vivo
y es que el padre la lucha contra el
racismo y el son mandela también
conocido como madiba nació el 18 de
julio de 1918 el objetivo de esta fecha
además de ser dar la vida y obra del
premio nobel de la paz es reflexionar
sobre la necesidad de erradicar el
racismo en todas sus formas así
finalizamos este capítulo de aplica
siete días pero antes los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web triple punto
france24 puntocom para ampliar la
información de américa latina y del
mundo quédense con nosotros nos vemos
más adelante
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]